la course facile c'est différent on va
pas revenir en arrière
[Musique]
tenez vous bien me dire il est favori
des pousses amoureux tu m'emmerdes à
m'engueuler mais c'est moi qui les tue
c'est moi qui les touchent et
d'autoroutes dans les mains
annie chroniqueurs
le plaisir ouais attendez je vais pas
faire
[Musique]
brossât alors effectivement je suis l'un
des seuls à l'avoir vue parce qu'il
voulait mon avis puisque je suis le seul
que sobre dans l'équipe tout est assez
incroyable je crois qu'il m'a dit il
paraît qu'en tout cas que c'est
spectaculaire c'est quelque chose qui va
voilà qui va bouleverser le paf
voilà que tous les choix générique on me
dit que sa mère
[Applaudissements]
la crise
donc avec une solution à la cgt c'est ce
soir que je te mets dépanner dans ta vie
[Musique]
des galeries boule de suif de vos
patients l'histoire d'une prostituée
l'irak
c'est la pire que vous faites là si vous
voulez la d'aller faire un tour
allez allez voir aller voir si je suis
pas sûr que c'est à vous merci sur sa
table
l'entrée est à 3 jo 2000
elle essaye de tous les côtés s'arrête
pas de vouloir rentrer c'est normal
c'est super intéressant ils peuvent
rentrer quand même
par contre qu'est ce que vous voulez de
moi j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien
écrit nul et revient avec une vanne une
[Musique]
boîte à des paillettes partout partout
mais je peux dire que je m'appelle
l'anaconda dix combattants
[Musique]